In 1928 when Walt Disney had Mickey Mouse
whistle on a steamboat and squeak his first
words he never realized how big his Disney
Princess franchise would be.
Maybe that’s why it took over 20 years for
him to release another Disney princess film
after 1937’s release of Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs.
These animated beauties have become so popular
with children and grownups alike that we all
know that one slipper can change a life or
that we can use a fork as a comb.
Still, there are a lot of facts we didn’t
realize about Disney’s Princess that are
surprising.
Subscribe and get ready for Screen Rant’s
list of ten Things You May Not Have Realized
About Disney Movie Princesses.
Mulan’s Kills in Mulan
Mulan is the first Disney Princess to not
be a Princess by blood or by marriage and
her character is based on a mythological character,
the Chinese epic hero Hua Mulan.
Still, with all of these facts the most astonishing
might be her kill count.
Mulan causes an avalanche that sweeps over
2000 Hun solders and her actions cause the
death of all but 6 of them.
Then on top of that one of the six that survive
is main villain Shan-Yu and she pins him to
a roof with her sword then Mushu fires a rocket
at him.
That’s a kill count of 1,994 plus one assisted
death of animated characters, making her the
biggest badass Princess around.
Elsa’s Voice Cast in Frozen
Disney’s 2013 smash hit, Frozen melted the
hearts of audiences with all the lovable characters
in the film but millions of little girls wanted
to be just one character.
Princess Elsa, the youngest sibling in the
film but what about Princess Greta?
That was her original name before the writers
settle on Elsa.
Since Princess Elsa is five and 18 years old
in the film, it took four actresses to perform
her voice.
Two for singing and two for dialogue with
Kristen Bell having the most screen time and
giving Princess Elsa the most voice-over actors
for a Disney Princess character.
Cinderella’s Shoe Size in Cinderella
There are thousands of versions around the
world of the mythical story of Cinderella
but none more popular than 1950’s Disney
film.
With over 400 actresses auditioning for the
title role they would be stunned to find out
that the name Cinderella wasn’t her real
name in previous stories.
Cinderella was a nickname but Disney felt
that it was a perfect name for a princess
and decided to use it as her real name.
In the sequels we also find out that her shoe
size was a tiny four and a half.
Being that the average woman’s foot size
is 7, now we know why her sister’s cut off
their toes in previous stories to fit into
the glass slipper.
Merida’s Hair in Brave
Originally titled, The Bear and the Bow; Disney’s
2012 animated film Brave follows the story
of Princess Merida who is determined to make
her own path in life.
She is the first Disney Princess to not have
a love interest in the film and the first
to have a biological brother.
Actually she has three brothers.
Still, her curly red hair is usually the most
stunning.
It is made up of 111,700 hairs that were generated
from over 1500 individually sculpted models.
Luckily she was animated or she would have
taken a long time to prepare her hair in the
morning and the film would have ran longer.
Snow White’s Age in Snow White in Snow White
and the Seven Dwarfs
Most little girls are fans of Disney Princesses,
they love dressing up as them and imagining
they will be these characters when they grow
up.
Little do they realize some of these Princesses
aren’t that much older than they are.
Belle is 17, Jasmine is 15 and coming in first
place as the youngest Disney Princess of all
time is Snow White at 14 years young.
She’s not allowed to drive, vote, drink
or smoke but she can live with seven men and
be swept off her feet by Prince Charming.
Jasmine’s Name in Aladdin
Princess Jasmine was based on a character
from an Arabic folktale called One Thousand
and One Nights but was almost named after
a character from another book.
She was originally going to be named Badroulbadour
from the book, Arabian Nights after the princess
that marries Aladdin in that book.
We can only imagine the fuss the marketing
team made when they were told to market merchandise
for Princess Badroulbadour.
Nice idea on the name change Disney, even
if we would like to have heard Robin Williams
tackle that name with his improv.
Pocahontas’ Tattoo in Pocahontas
Pocahontas is the only Disney Princess to
be based on a real character and most believe
her to be the first Native American Disney
Princess but Tiger Lily from 1953’s Peter
Pan is actually the first.
She does have a few more firsts though.
She is the first to never change her costume
and never wear a tiara like her other Disney
Princess counterparts.
She is also, the first and only Princess to
have a tattoo.
Well, maybe she’s the only one who has shown
it and the others are shy still.
Auroa Screen Time in Sleeping Beauty
Auroa is the only Disney Princess to have
her first film be a commercial flop, only
grossing 5.3 million dollars on a budget of
6 million dollars.
Maybe it’s because of her lack of screen
time, she is only on screen for 18 minutes
of the 76 minute film and coincidentally only
has 18 lines of dialogue.
Or maybe it has to do with the 6 years it
took Princess Aurora to arrive on screen,
since Walt Disney was preoccupied with building
Disneyland and kept holding up production
of the film.
Rapunzel’s Hair Length in Tangled
Princess Rapunzel might have been the first
Disney Princess to grace the silver screen
since her story was worked on as a concept
before Walt Disney settled on Snow White and
the Seven Dwarfs.
Not surprisingly she is the Disney Princess
with the longest hair but did you know she
also has the shortest hair.
After cutting her hair she beat out Snow White
for that honor over seventy years after she
was passed up for her own feature film.
Belle’s Sisters in Beauty and the Beast
Beauty and the Beast is the only animated
Disney film starring a Princess that has been
nominated for a Best Picture Academy Award.
This has to do with the wonderful story that
the filmmakers delivered.
Though, in earlier drafts of the script Belle
had a two sister that were nowhere near as
kind and loving as Belle.
Then a next draft the writer combined the
sisters into a single character, Marguerite,
Belle's aunt, who shared several similar characteristics
to the sisters.
All three characters we written out and we
have the charming film we have today.
What do you think of our video?
Did we skip over any other Things You May
Not Have Realized About Disney Movie Princesses?
Sound off in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more fun videos
like this one!
Thanks for watching!